one of the biggest things i worry about
as well is just the chemistry because
sometimes i see people collab and like
you know that's
you you can tell on camera that that's
the first time ever yeah
yeah had like had a like irl
conversation yeah exactly
i actually recently did a video where i
got my fortune told in japan
and i even yeah and uh there's like two
things that are happening so i show like
the actual raw footage of me talking to
the fortune teller i had never
met her before in my life so my
introvertedness actually came out in
that where i only said like
one word answers but to be fair i was
also listening because she had a lot to
say
it was a lot for me to process but then
there's the part of me that's like in my
room where i was
actually very outspoken and i think i
even said in that video i'm like yeah
you're looking at two different augies
here
that aki right there is actually the
introverted one and i'm just listening
the ones
that's the real one no but and then the
one that you're seeing right now is just
my thoughts and i'm comfortable to get
them out right now
because i i think when we hang out it's
like very different to when we hang out
and there's someone else there you don't
really know yeah yeah
pretty much and that's then that's with
every like anyone that like
you know when there's someone that's new
i mean again like i've learned this in
psychology but you tend to look at the
person that you're most comfortable with
even if you're talking
to someone else it's like yeah uh you
guys went to that park right yeah um
okay yeah
like i language just says so much about
it and i'm definitely sorry i'm making
eye contact right away i'm just like hi
i actually had to learn how to make eye
contact because that's a skill
i think you know as a kid i was like a
socially awkward kid i'd be talking
i'd be talking to someone and be like
yeah how's your day going yeah it's
i have no idea where i learned social
skills how do you learn that [ __ ] i
swear i was terrible
i don't know you just i think you're
just like especially when you become an
adult
you're forced to because like if you're
that one like adult where
you just can't maintain i can't talk to
anyone as a kid like i was terrible yeah
i never learned
like i've never i've never talked to
someone and being like i have to keep
looking into their eyes i have
really actually there's there's been one
anime that's been airing this season
um and it's like we just need to remind
you guys that this is an anime podcast
because it's like relevant to me and
that's why i really uh i'm watching it
and it's like
i think it's like jakku or something
like that is a bottom tier character
oh yeah yeah yeah it's about this like
pro gamer who has like zero social
skills and he meets
like this hot anime girl it's like it's
like a harem rom-com but
the premise is that she teaches him
social skills
like they're a game so like he like he
she he she gamifies
she gave her questions look at the eyes
exactly she's just like okay so
this this brought this person bought up
x topic and that like really
defined the flow of this conversation
and it really like broke down
like social skills and social circles
and like gamified them and that was like
really interesting to me because
that's basically what i had to do in
university because i was just like
this is not natural to me i've got to
[ __ ] engineer this [ __ ]
and then and then it became second
nature along the way but like i needed
those training wheels
when i was learning it because i was
like that socially awkward
but that's like a cool way to learn it
right like because it's like it's a
concept that you can kind of
understand yeah it's like i think
there's a healthy way and an unhealthy
way to go about it because some people
just like take this and like gamify it
too much that they just kind of become a
robot and i feel like it's it's healthy
it's like look at this person and then
look at this person and then look at
this person
it's just it's just helpful it's just
helpful it's like it's kind of like
training wheels eye contact is hard like
too little and then you're like
talk to me too much it's like i've met
those people where it's like
hard eye contact that just they don't
even blink i'm just like that's
like i'm talking to an android you just
occasionally look right look away look
back
yeah yeah yeah i don't know what's
happening you know exactly exactly
who teaches this [ __ ] how do i learn
this [ __ ] i don't know no one does no
one does teach you you know it's one
thing that drives me insane that
some people do and some people don't do
if okay let's say we're all here right
and then you know let's say aki brings a
friend okay to the group
it drives me insane when the person who
brought the friend in doesn't introduce
them to everyone
yeah i'm waiting who is this person
they're
yeah i've had times where because that
person didn't do it yeah
i've had to awkwardly go up to be like
oh i'm joey by the way yeah yeah i don't
have to be who are you by the way
yeah should be like aki connor connor
yankee yeah do you know one
by the way do it right away do you know
one of the biggest things that i found
is important even though i never thought
about it as like a kid
the handshake yeah
now that we've met now that we've gone
through like met so many people you can
judge so much about a person by just
their handshake
yeah exactly yeah exactly it's an entire
process and it's like an entire science
behind it
sometimes someone whips out like the
weakest handshake and you're just you're
not looking forward to this hand
it is
or like you know when they just do this
and they're just waiting for you yeah
sometimes
sometimes you just feel like you're
grabbing like a dead piece of me and
you're just like
hello how how are you i love it when the
the strength comes out they turn their
body slightly yeah the shoulder needs to
come out
that's how you know they they're like
keen for the hamstrings honestly if you
want to make a good impression
handshakes are so
[ __ ] op yeah right they are they
really are
but the the strongest ones that i've
learned is like you know the
the shoulder out front a little bit but
also going in
while maintaining eye contact like that
don't even look at the hands
that's what my dad did to you the first
time he met you yeah
that was more of like uh saying a
message when he did it like this like
just shake
if i was like my dad and you were joey
it's like
he like whipped the hand out i was like
oh [ __ ] i have to catch this
yeah and then after that i remember like
uh that my dad he boxes and we have also
like a sandbag in our garage
and then like joey's just like you want
to see the uh my new sandbag and he
[ __ ] punches the [ __ ] out of him he's
like oh it's pretty good huh
yeah and i was like maintain eye contact
yeah but yeah my life's kind of weird
i'm sorry